hello everyone and welcome back at the
de-clutch international it's the finals
Magnus Carlsen versus Fabiano Kerwin a
world number two versus world number one
and this is Game three Game one and game
two ended in a draw and this one is
quite the game so without further ado
let's check it out so Magnus with the
white pieces opens with D for Fabi goes
for Knight to f6 and Bishop to f4 Magnus
goes for his London set up we have d5
and III we have c5 by Fabi air striking
in the center and Knight to f3 Magnus
continues development tonight the c6 and
the knight B to D to Magnus prefers this
then then rather than going for the c3
idea and now Fabi goes for the dark
square Bishop right away with knife to
h4 unnecessary Knight to h5 now the
bishop is under attack and well for the
moment doing a good job preventing black
from from going e5 so here we have D
captures on c5 still another problem
still have sufficient control of e5 and
here Bobby grabs at Knight captures on
a4 pawn captures and Queen to a5 now
just preparing to win the c5 pawn so
Magnus continues development with Bishop
to d3 and Queen captures on c5 this was
all played before and it's not nothing
new Magnus castles and the g6 now Fabi
prepares the Finca to his dark square
bishop as it will be very useful in this
diagonal and here there is one game in
the database for Knights that if I was
played but Magnus goes the Knights the
b3 with an attack on the Queen and it is
as a move tendered we have a completely
new game so let's see what Bobby comes
up with he shifts the Queen over to d6
will come in handy if at some point you
want to strike with e5 we have Queen to
d2 by Magnus connecting rooks and at
some point I believe in the pock champs
championship there was a term was coined
when you connect rooks that the ropes
become Bros for life now I don't know I
kind of enjoyed this term so I thought
you guys would enjoy hearing about it so
Queen d2 connecting rooks Bishop to g7
now if in carrying the dark square
Bishop and now c3 numbing the
the darks were bishop and also taking
away some nice squares from the dark
knight on c6 finally fabbi castles and
now rook ft-1 getting the rook into the
game and now Bishop to g4 putting
pressure on the night for the moment the
e5 square is off-limits for the white
knight as it is defended three times so
you cannot use the outpost so quinta III
now just defending the knight and here
Fabi decides to grab the Knight Bishop
captures Queen captures and East six now
and black has a very solid position here
and h4 by Magnus he wants to play h5
bust open the position however Fabi says
no you don't he goes h5 himself and now
g3 creating some light Square weaknesses
around the white king but you still have
a light square bishop so if needed if
black goes for some sort of an attack
you can always just ship the Bishop her
to defense if such such a thing is
needed so look if the e8 Bobby gets the
rook into the game he will bring this
rook to b8 and then maybe even go for
this 'if I've idea
we have rook a to d8 and now a six Fabi
first precursor a further expand on the
Queen side and now a very interesting
move Magnus goes night to d2 and now the
night from d2 can be useful for a lot of
things you can play c4 for example at
some point you can go Knights to f12
maybe III but fabi's next move allows
Magnus to really make use of this knife
here Fabi plays b5 just a nice nice
expanding move maybe you can bring your
knight let's say to the c4 perhaps but
also just just a nice expansion and you
can bring your your rook into the game
on the next move however this allows
Magnus to go for Knight to e4 and it's a
it's a very tricky idea because if the
knight is captured then the ship
captures opens up an attack on the Queen
and a double attack on the night here
and if you don't want to lose terribly
and face captures followed by a double
attack you will have to go Knight the d4
now you free up your pin piece by
attacking whites Queen and here we would
see rook captures still win an attack on
the Queen Bishop characters here in our
burst of characters on a8 and
once the bishop retreats white just has
an extra pawn and end a very enjoyable
position so instead after this Knight to
e4 idea father moves back Queen to d7
and now Knight to g5 and now after
Magnus grabs hold of the g5 Square it's
incredibly difficult to kick this night
away from here you could you could kick
it away with f6 but that's just really
weakening the Kings position then Jesus
becomes weak ecigs becomes a week and
it's it's something you never do so
Fabi just continues rook 8b8 mobilizes
all of his pieces and now Bishop to C to
a clearing the D file for the rook but
also in anticipation of b4 prepares
Bishop to a4 and this is indeed fabi's
next move Bobby took some time to come
up with his idea here and after playing
before Magnus did call for Bishop to a4
there was the sort of critical line g4
but it maybe maybe requires a bit too
much time to calculate and it is a rapid
game so point is after you everything
straight it let's say captures captures
captures and captures that the Queen
will be very strong here and h5 will be
will be a very nice threat and also for
example if Bishop captures and c3 yes
you have to give up the pawn but after
rookie three let's say Bishop before
root goes back still the the position
remains and the White has a lot of
attacking potential here in the position
so it was possible however Magnus goes
for Bishop to a4 instead puts pressure
on the night which is a much more
natural idea and here if I be just
captures this was his plan all along we
have B captures on c3 and now you need
to you need to prepare for g4 somehow
maybe play rook to f8 rook to e7 add
another defender to the TF 7 point as it
could be a bit dangerous
however Fabi decided to unpin and here
he played the Queen to c8 but now
incredible as it as it is the position
is lost for Fabi and it's not easy to
spot why but you know you are in your
own home I presume
comfortable.i I hope you guys are warm
also so feel free to pause the video and
try to find the winning idea for Magnus
while I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on really finding a
beautiful line and for those who just
want to enjoy the show it's f5 f5 in
combination with c4 but not c4 followed
by f5 as it is different I'm just gonna
show it for example if c4 first of
course black cannot capture as the night
would be hanging the Queen and Bishop
are nicely attacking it so this is what
black would do you would unpin with
Knight to d4 attack White's Queen again
the same idea and then we would have
this trade rook captures Bishop captures
captures captures and now C captures and
e5 e captures rook captures ending it
with Czech captures and now you get this
position where you can push f5 try and
bust open the position but the black can
just ignore you with let's say jeez a
King g7 and it's not as potent as
pushing f5 right away from that position
even though this is also much better for
white however here Magnus played f5
first and this is just much more
crushing because you don't allow black
to really really trade everything off
because if you don't react to this if
you try something well anything let's
say you try rook to f8 you're gonna get
F capture send g6 captures and Queen to
d3 and now there are so many weaknesses
here this is a weakness this is a
weakness this is a weakness the e6 pawn
to g6 bone is a weakness so everything
is a weakness here and the black will
not with withstand all the pressure so
another thing you could do after f5 is
ago for example he captures an f5 but
then he just removed the defender of the
d5 pawn rook captures any eight check
captures and Queen captures here now
again with a double attack on the knight
and the double attack on the f7 pawn
there is no there's no defending this so
Bobby did the third thing he decided to
capture with the Jeep on but now you
weaken the H pawn and also now c4 is
incredibly strong because you just
thread
- completely bust open the position
there's still the problem of this night
here of the pin here and Fabi here goes
ninth to d4 as nah it's a similar line
to the one we've shown only now G
captures an f5 was already played so
this is very important for the position
so rook captures on d4 like in the
previous line Bishop captures on d4 we
have captures captures and now Queen
captures on h5 but now it's different
because of just captures the Queen is
threatening to capture here and follow
it by Queen h7 checkmate or the other
way around just check and checkmate so
you have to defend it and here rook to
e7 maybe is is also possible or Queen to
d7
however fabric late Queen to c7 and this
is giving giving Carson's attack a bit
too much wind as now the rook here is
undefended so here he didn't make it a
bit easier for Magnus but whatever he
did was also completely losing so here
seek out force on d5
you cannot recapture because of rook
captures any age with the check so look
the e7 now adds another defender here
but now Magnus just grabs the e6 pawn as
well here Fabi kicks away the knight
would have six but now Queen g6 check
very tricky because rook here you get
Queen here with checkmate the knight is
covering the h7 square there's nowhere
to go for the King so after queen g6
check King the f8 was played but now
Knight back to f3 in getting the knight
out of harm's way but with temple
attacking the bishop here and after
Bishop to c3 what Fabi played Magnus
played rook the c1 and now there's a lot
of pressure on this Bishop here and it's
not easy for black to even find a move
for example if you any move you play
like let's say try rook g7 not allow any
checks the bishop guards DF 6 points so
that's not that's off-limits but let's
say Queen h6 now with ideas or just
check King here and grabbing the rook
let's say King G 8 and now Queen e3
there's no saving the bishop so all
sorts of tricks are in the position so
after this rook to see one move Bobby
tried rook captures on e6 but now it's
the same idea there are a lot of ways of
course you could play this Magnus played
Knight the d4
now again making use of this pin of
course you cannot capture the Queen
Hanks attacks the rook attacks the f5
point so Bobby has to play something
rook the b6 and now he goes for the idea
that we've already mentioned as it's
important to see that the rook is unable
to join the defence of the bishop disc
Square is covered by the knight and also
the square by the knight and the pond so
rook will not be able to help out with
the defense of the bishop so it only
means one thing
Queen to h6 check and you bring the
Queen into the attack on the bishop King
g8 and now Quinta III with a double
attack on the bishop here and it was in
this position unmoved 37 that Fabiana
Khurana resigned the game in the game 3
goes to Magnus who takes the lead in the
clutch international finals so here we
resign as there is nothing more to be
done here and the bishop capture sandy
for although it looks very interesting
since it kind of offers the Queen trade
not really because of Queen e8 trick and
you just get to checkmate at King g7
captures with cheque you lose the Queen
and here it's just a nice checkmate with
rook or queen to h7 doesn't really
matter
so far we've course saw this and after
23 he resigned the game so really really
impressive stuff again Magnus gets a win
against such an elite player like Fabi
with none other than the London system
and I always remember what kramnik said
after after he lost the kramnik after he
lost the Carlsen in the world blitz
championship in the previous one where
Carlson went for the London system and
Kramnik said in an interview after the
game yes I I lost but the London system
is still bad however Magnus is good so
that's it's the way it is so once again
I do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Jacob Gonzalez a Peter man Thomas
Jenkins Debashish gopalan and David
visual off-screen for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous video serum thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the clutch
just International finals checking up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the chess world thank
you all I will see you soon and heaven
unrest everyday